>> RUBY: Sorry about all this. My name is
Sam Ruby. IBM, Emerging Technology, Co-chair
of W3C HTML working group and I work from
the FeedValidator, and that's--that's a bit
relevant to some of the topics I'm bringing
up. I share a lot of Brad's perspectives and
actually, you'll see--we'll actually share
some tapes and music, and not music, and movies.
All these slides will be up on the Web. You
can see the link here but it will be up for
everybody to get to, and there'll be links.
I also have a Weblog. The Weblog has a fair
amount of SVG, every single one of my--okay.
Every single one of my entries has got an
SVG element. I've done that for now for like
several years. Most of them are completely
handcrafted. I was going to demo that, though
I can't--for technical reasons that are preventing
me from actually demoing the editing MBI,
which is just as exciting as it sounds. [laugh]
These are all in line SVG elements off serve
as application XHTML plus XML, and I do some
special magic to make SVG Web work with this
on IE. So, even though, this is not officially
supported, I supported it anyway. [pause]
That's not just on every image. I do some
creative things to show the same images on
my archive's page. So, you can actually see
on various days what I posted on and go to
them. That's--it's very helpful to be able
to see just an image and that helps you quickly
find the entry you want to find on a Weblog.
[pause] My site is called Intertwingly because
I tend to believe that things are often intermixed
and related and interesting and on different
ways and sometimes not so wonderful ways.
A lot of the things--Brad said, "This works."
Like, for example, you can search into hypertext
links; just use the little asterisk next to
that. It works just as long you do this to
the other but not if you do this other third
thing. Now that third thing is the thing that
you end up finding out accidentally when you
run into it not because it's well documented
everywhere. And I'll show an example of two
of that. So, the things are often all knotted
up. Ground rules. This is--everything I'm
presenting here as I've said will be online
here.
As you see it already is. Most important stuff
first, if I happen to run over time I just
will kind of cut short. What I really mean
by that is feel free to ask questions. This
is the reasonable response of the audience
where if you've got something to say that's
fine. The presentation contains some code
but this is all faster when it's [INDISTINCT].
Don't focus on the details. Focus on the social
ramifications. That's really what I'm here
to talk about. [pause] Question to the audience,
how did you learn HTML? Reading the spec?
[laugh] Formal education? There are classes
on this stuff. Still no hands? [pause] Come
on. From a book? There are books. Hey, we
got a couple of books and view source. Okay.
That's to be expected. [pause] Change the
question to SVG. How many people learned SVG
from reading the spec? [laugh] It's a different--okay,
formal education, from a book and view source.
Okay. For me I started with the spec. For
HTML it was--of course, it was the other way
around and augmented with view source. Where's
the source? A typical site, like this one,
it happens to have some SVG but you don't
get to see it. It's not really SVG that's
shown there for various technical reasons.
But hidden away in this particular one in
a link, if you go to "About" and scroll to
the bottom, you might actually be able to
find there's a link to the Header Graphics.
And if you go there, you'll find an SVG image
and--I don't know what the key button is for
view source but I'll--okay, I might just have
backed up. You can--I'll try to do it. View
source, page source, let's see. That's the
wrong source. [pause] What was that? That's
fine. Okay. It's not so important in this
case. [pause] So in this one case, you can
get to it but it's not that obvious. Let me
contrast something else that's a little more
vital than SVG has been to date. PHP, lots
of people code in PHP and one convention they've
got is on their website. Even though PHP is
all service side stuff, at the bottom of every
single page they've got, right next to their
item link, is a show source button that will
actually show the source of the server code.
So, this is very helpful for getting people
to learn PHP. They can actually see it on
the site and actually view the source and
use it. You don't tend to see that as often
in SVG, and that's something I think needs
to be improved. More people's experience is
they see this little mushroom and they learn
SVG that way. It's sort of hidden for them
because it's actually taken care of. It's--this
is the icon for Inkscape. If they do happen
to view source, what they see is this. [laugh]
Some people call this name Space Form. Okay.
This is not the ideal way to learn SVG. Jeff,
I presume, will be talking about Scour later.
I see a hand. Okay. [pause] If that was a
question, the question--the--what he asked
was that the idea was to split them into small
pieces, we have learned to individual small
pieces. My experience has been--it almost
takes hand-editing to get to the point where
it's basically a teaching aid. Things that
are generated by code tend to look like they
were generated by a code. And I'll show you
in a second, view source sounds good, but
what's the downside? This is--I'll come back
to that in a second. View source sounds good,
but what's the downside? And as I said, we
got somewhere testing movies. You have to
be willing to seek the truth. You have to
take the red pill. This is where you get to
see the grungy side. This is the--where you
actually go down and see the truth as it really
is. And I'll touch on that in on a number
of aspects to that in my presentation, in
particular, obviously how much to the matrix.
Tolerance is a key aspect. And I want to tell
you my tolerance in a couple of different
ways. First, Postel's law; be conservative
in what you do, liberal on what you accept
from others. This is controversial right now
in the HTML and SVG communities. The idea
that SVG when put in HTML context the browser
will tend to view it in a very tolerant fashion,
which means if someone misses a quote, they'll
try to still render it. That is controversial
in a sense that you can then put some HTML.
When you're done, you got something--you might
not go take back out. And you still will be
able to. Mime type, text HTML, mime type is
forgiving. If you send it as HTML, it will
be forgiving. If you send it as application
XHTML plus XML, it's called draconian. If
it fails--if it's got a parse error, nothing
will display. And how much to another movie,
choose wisely. That's a link to Indiana Jones.
XHTML, service tech XHTML is not processed
as XML, just to show about the red pill aspects
of it. CSS acts differently, JavaScript acts
differently, namespaces don't work. It's parsed
differently. A couple of just aspects to that,
actually, it's parsed subtly different, which
makes it worse. It's not like it's black and
white, it almost works almost all the time.
And then there are one or two edge cases.
Linked to more details, but it really, each
one can give us some highlights. Script source
sequels and you give something; you use the
slash greater than. Despite the fact that
I have done this for a number of years, I
still trip over this to this day every once
in a while. When you do that in HTML, it eats
the rest of your page. Basically, the entire
rest of the pages are treated as if they're
manuscripts waiting on the network. I apologize
for all of this. But it does eat the rest
of the page in texthtml mode because it's
looking for an end close to the script tag.
If you got br slash br, so you take the opposite
thing, which you'll say, "Okay, I can't always
use the closing thing so I'll actually use
the opposite." That's treated as two line
breaks in HTML mode. It's just the way browsers
are implemented. So I actually got code in
some of my source that does things, like,
these are the list of five, ten, eleven, twelve
elements that--can you stop closing the elements.
And that's what you should use on everything
else you're not, and then next path expression,
which says find all that elements that have--don't
have sub-children and don't have text. And
if so, out of text note. This is the code
that we'll be using our XML that will basically
clean up XML before you serialize it. Things
you got to deal with if you wish to remain
using XML tools to do this. Another subtle
different pre-line, close pre, this is a pre-form
editing in HTML. In HTML that's one line.
It shows that it goes one line, so what do
you expect? Next HTML, what you see is actually
two lines; a line break followed by one line
because in XHTML, the pre-element is followed
by a new line, and that new line is actually
in the dot, subtle differences that will trip
you up if you want to keep using XHTML mode.
So, XHTML has been preached for a long time,
particularly by W3C. It's not necessarily
something I would recommend despite the fact
that it's what I pretty much exclusively use.
And this presentation itself is XHTML, which
is sort of what--is required right now today
to do this demo. Tolerance means, tolerance
of user mistakes, tolerance of different values
and perspectives. How many Anchor Tags in
the following, how many A Tags do you see
there? One, two? The right answer is one.
The reason why it's Plain Text is a element
that says the rest of the page is--be treated
as it is. It's sort of an archaic element.
It's strongly deprecated but it's still implemented
by all the browsers today. And the next question
is, where does that anchor point? It actually
points before the table. The reason why is
browsers today, when they see the Table Tag,
you can't actually render a table until you
actually read the contents. They come through
the table and they get to this thing that
doesn't belong in the table, and says, "What
shall I do with this?" And historically, their
choices were to throw it away or just simply
render it right now and get back to the--doing
my table and then render the table. So what
it ends up doing it is it ends up reordering
the page. This is how browsers are forgiving.
These are things that end up making lives
more difficult. [pause] The good news is there
are tools, like HTML2XML and XHTML, XML2HTML
that can take all these things and give you
the clean output that matches precisely HTML
files behavior. An HTML files behavior is
engineered to exactly to what browsers are
doing. So what I'm saying here, here's all
the messy things. These--what I'm saying,
here's a tool that can help you and hopefully
there'll be more. [pause] Three ways to embed
SVG; you can use an Object Tag. This is what's
been documenting HTML standard for years.
You can use that bag tag which was what Netscape
has been using, but it hasn't been documented
to HTML5. An image source is sort of what
most people would think to use and want to
use. [pause] Guess which one doesn't work
in Firefox today? [pause] Here I chuckle.
I assume that's because you know. [pause]
Right, Image Source doesn't work. Anybody
guess why?
>> The security.
>> RUBY: I don't think it's obvious. The security,
he's got the right answer. It seems odd to
me that you look at this and this is just
syntax. So, somebody is just producing syntax.
It's just another spelling way of doing it,
but it turns out object embed intentionally
create boxes or sandboxes as it were, and
they do that upfront and the secure thought
given to that. An image they say, "I--I'm
just going to assume what's going to go."
It's okay. It's just a bit of bunch of bits.
Well, it turns out SVG is not just a bunch
of bits. It can add dynamic behavior. That
dynamic behavior could do things like leak
passwords, capture clicks, and that is kind
of scary. Now, Firefox is the only browser
right now that doesn't--right now, Opera.
And WebKit do support SVG with an Image Tag.
They only support a subset of it though; they
do not support scripting behavior of it. So
that's an example of where it seems like it
should all work, but that's why there's a
little asterisk that says, "Ah, but if you
do it this way, you can't do the other things."
So, like, if you have a Hypertext links if
you do it with an image tag. [pause]
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> RUBY: Sure. Sure, what?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> RUBY: [pause] Inline versus Embed. My page
uses Inline. Here's an embedded image and
here's an Inline image. They look about the
same. And in my screen, they actually look
closer together, but that's cool. [pause]
This has got a hypertext link on the embedded
image. As we show an example of why the hypertext
or why the embedded image is a Sandbox. If
you click on the link, what you're actually
going to see is the actual Webpage that it's
linked to in kind of a very small place because
it was Sandboxed. The exact same image Inline
gives you a link to the page. It behaves differently
depending on how you do that. So these are
the things where--it should all just work
and you should get all these behaviors, but
at the end you're finding out that they're
not quite. [pause] SVG integrates better with
XHTML, and you can do more. That's how I do
it, but nobody uses XHTML. And by that, I
mean the Mime type, actually almost nobody.
I--I do. [pause] Is SVG XHTML the answer?
[pause] A couple of issues by and large, it
is, graceful degradation. If you do SVG Inline,
not Brad's way, which is using the Script
Tag, you have to do things like avoid the
self-closing tags. So, your SVG images need
to use Path, close Path. If you want to have
the page, service text XHTML and actually
processed properly by some browsers. Okay.
It turns out there are techniques to get to
work without the self-closing tags with IE,
and that's--that you serve everybody but IE,
Application XHTML plus XML, you're okay. But
most of you don't want to use the actual Mime
type because that means it got to be draconian.
[pause] The other issue is unknown tags maybe
ignored, but the naked text will be displayed.
So if you're marking a CDATA, XML will treat
that as if it were a text and HTML will treat
that as a comment. Later, I worked around
and so over time I've developed because I've
been developing this stuff. [pause] SVG is
valid in HTML file. It's part of the spec
so that you can actually include it. [pause]
Other name spaces are not.
>> Except MathML.
>> RUBY: MathML, yes, and NxLink. Almost all
generated SVG I've seen, actually probably
generated SVG I've seen contains some foreign
namespace. So if you copy and paste that into
a document, you will get validation errors
that will tend to discourage the use of SVG
Inline. That will undermine the credibility
of the validator. That's not good social engineering.
[pause] I say it's not currently validated.
It's actually under active discussion. [pause]
There's a bug report, it opened, that's in
active debate on how it should be dealt with.
The current says that the bug report is as
follows: HTML defines a mapping of the bytes
to DOM, and an element names may contain a
colon. When it gets into DOM, you might have
a colon on the element names. SVG defines
a valid set of elements in the SVG Namespace,
but SVG does not currently define element
names with a colon. So could you have a RTF
colon about element name in SVG's Namespace?
Is that valid? There is no spec right now
that says "That is valid." Notice it's "RDF:about".
It's not RDF expanded to some prefix to the
RDF Namespace, it's literally a character
string, "RDF:" So these things are kind of
on the edge. And again, social engineering
aspects are what I really don't like, which
is people who try to use SVG find out that
they just copy and paste. Then all of a sudden,
the validator says, "You're doing it bad."
And trust me, most users or validators aren't
that sophisticated. They just say it's--"I'm
doing it bad. What am I doing wrong?" Yes,
can you speak up?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> RUBY: Okay, I always use the word "DOM"
not necessarily literally. Basically, a lot
of the information that I know are built on
"DOMs". There is actually no requirement that
HTML is--requires a "DOM". It's just a short-hand
way of saying "This is how you represent it
in an abstract tree. So no, I wasn't implying
any sort of implementation. I was being imprecise.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> RUBY: No, that's fine. Okay, so the current
stance at the moment is that it's not valid.
And again, I find that unfortunate for a social
engineering perspective. The other one is
Microsoft has got a proposal for allowing
Namespaces in HTML syntax. And that's under
an act to debate too and we'll see how that
one goes. This is a link to the proposal that
just came out probably two days ago. And people
were noticing a bit that that doesn't match
IE's behavior in a number of interesting ways.
And so that's--it impede its ability to succeed.
Validation in general--yes? [pause]. Yes,
at the moment, they are not actively saying
that. They're actually participating in discussion,
but actually not into making clear statements
like, "We are going to implement this, et
cetera. It's just--it's out for discussion.
So at the moment, it's a little unclear. I'm--obviously
actively watching it. I'm very hopeful, because
I would actually like to see Namespaces work.
The idea of validation in general, I think,
is something we need to rethink as a community.
Google.com, if you validate it, it's got a
whole bunch of errors. And yet, I don't believe
any browser in the world could ship--that
did not support Google's Homepage. I think
that's a requirement. These errors as it were
are not accidental oversights. I don't believe
that Google doesn't have the resources to
address this. I believe they are intentional.
They are put in there and saying, "Look, we
can save four bytes by loosing the M--three
bytes, by loosing, "MP;" because it doesn't
matter. All the browsers are implemented in
the same way. So it's almost like we need
another mode of validation that says "Let
me--just tell me the things that do matter,"
versus, "Here's all the things that where
at somebody's opinion that this not the right
way to do it." So I'm showing some of my own
personal opinion on how validations work and
I'm starting to invest some time in backing
that up by working on the validator, the HTML5
validator. Now, the dangers that warn about
it are real. You can actually--if you don't--actually,
when you just put an ampersand without caring
what goes after it. You can actually get entities
accidentally that you didn't need to. It's
rare but it can happen. But they only play
in certain circumstances. And they only--and
they may not apply the situations where they
validate that your site has a bug. So a lot
of people are choosing to ignore the validator.
And most--many cases amount to recommendations.
For example, font is treated as non-performing
because style is preferred. So you can make
a generic transformation of Font Tags into
span style equals in the same--the font stuff.
And you add a "no value". You have not changed
the behavior one bit. You've not changed the
number of browsers reported, not changed the
breadth or the media independence of it one
bit. And all of a sudden, one is valid and
the other one is not. Omitted End Tags are
more likely to cause hardy debug problems.
You're allowed to omit End Tags for list items,
for example. More likely it will cause problems
but that's not flagged. [pause]. My first
SVG was this comp bench. This is the first
thing I ever did. I did it by flying on an
airplane, bored out of my mind. I had the
SVG spec, I had a cute little tool, but this
is actually the source. You can actually take
a look at this source. And this source is
an example of source that looks it was edited
by a human because it was. It's the stuff
I did five or six years ago. I mean a post,
a foot, the back, a seat, and then a box of
chocolates. And the bench has got a lot of
used statements which you don't tend to see
in generated code. It uses affordance--more
for human authors, in my opinion that says,
"I have this one reusable element. I apply
it three or four times." So it got--the benches
got slats. I've got--several foot, a couple
of posts and the like, and I apply it with--just
changing "X" and "Y". This looks like a code
and you could say, "I could pick that up and
change it. I can modify it." It looks like
it was edited by a human. And again, I used
a tool called "Batik", which we have one of
the main authors out right here. All I did
on the airplane. I had three windows up, AVI,
as editing and text, another window, I use
command prompt that use JAVA--the name of
the JAVA for Batik, and actually converted
that to an image. Another was just a browser
to see the image. And I had time to kill and
just one by one, I edited this thing and went
through the build cycle, et cetera. It sounds
boring as all; I now do it as my demo with
how I do it today, which is a little faster
but still boring as it all get out. It passes
the time and it's actually, it's been interesting
and educational to me. The demo was how I
took an image for--that looks kind of like
the Internet Explorer, actually the--the old
version of the Internet Explorer logo. Took
an image of that--it's certainly like Chrome
and I don't actually have--be able to do the
demo, but I built this image that looks kind
of like a mash-up of the two. This is what
I've been using my--on my Web blog to talk
about the--I call it ChromeIE, Chrome-I-E,
but it's a Chrome plug in a Google Chrome
Frame. Google Chrome Frame--I want to just
review it right now in the context of SVG.
It doesn't support application/XHTML + XML.
You cannot serve that Mime type and have Google
Chrome Frame take it. That kind of blows me
out of the water because that's the Mime type
I'm using. But few people do use that Mime
type. That's not a big problem. The only real
problem is that high percentage of people
do make keynotes. [laugh] It does support
image source sequels, because that's one thing
Web--it does. Unfortunately, I would not recommend
it because you can't do things like animation,
and if you do that you can't use Firefox,
which cuts you out of a good portion of the
browser market that does support SVG. This
is another example, one of those asterisk
so, don't go there, it does support embed.
So, the embed tag works. So if you actually
didn't want to use SVG in Google Chrome Frame,
use XHTML and embed, because this is one of
those--you can get there from here but only
this way type of passing and I seem to find
a lot of those. Links are Sandboxed as I showed
you. If you actually have a hypertext link
in an embed tag, it'll actually just show
up inside that little Sandbox, it's not quite
what you might want. And content negotiation
can be improved by discussing it on a Web
blog, that's really outside of the scope of
this. Wrapping up, recommendations from ATU;
show your source. If you got SVG on your site,
go out of your way to try to make it obvious
and how to find the source to it. Be tolerant
of users, you know, there's people who built
SVG are going to make mistakes. Figure out
a way to deal with the persons that actually
use the same URL, if nothing else, they outnumber
you. Specs that seem arbitrary generally aren't.
There are lots of rules and things are built
in specs and will say, people have all sorts
of interesting debates, but they take one
side of the other and say, obviously it's
got to be this way. You're looking at one
aspect to the problem and somebody else is
looking at a completely different aspect and
comes with a completely different conclusion.
That's why most of the debates I see are happening.
There are actually are reasons for most of
these things. And my last real comment is
we need multiple--log out your profiles. I
actually do believe that Namespaces inside
SVG, that's copied and pasted, you probably
should not get the same level of warning or
error as things are just put randomly in HTML.
So figuring out exactly when and where, that's
going to be interesting. People have strong
debates and whatever. And it might just be
we--we have to move away from profiles and
validate each. And I forgot what time we're
supposed to end but, well, ahead of time,
or on time, or what? Okay. Questions? (pause)
Yes. (pause) Am I an inventor of SVG? No,
I just happened to be a user of SVG who has
been using it now for several years on his
Web blog and I found some interesting issues
and I just stand by to let you know. (pause)
One of the original.
>> Have you [INDISTINCT]? (laughs) Anyone
else contributed [INDISTINCT], any other [INDISTINCT]?
>> RUBY: I've contributed.
>> These are the most [INDISTINCT].
>> RUBY: Okay. I would second that. I've been
using it for years, I've enjoyed it, despite
the fact that my pitch sounds a bit of a downer
but it's--he actually is somewhat excited
and do want to try to work through the issues.
>> Okay, thank you, Sam.
>> RUBY: Okay.